eric romneycare fait décidément chaque
semaine un peu plus fort et on s'en
plaint pas dans un genre un peu
différent disons dans un genre western
la tribu de roger siffer h/f dans le
cercle et strasbourg ce soir ils sont en
effet à hautepierre c'est là bas qu'ils
ont planté leur tipi pour leur
avant-dernier au pot alors un reportage
tout de suite du sorcier gilles chavanel
amoura de nous
hier les artistes se sont parfois
transformé en cerbère le public enfants
de la meinau a été particulièrement
bruyants et dissiper mais quelles que
soient les circonstances il faut assurer
et ils ont assuré jusqu'à la quête là
les nerfs ont craqué pour rire bien sûr
la france aux côtés des forces
espérance
et
il est jeune
ce concert
pour la première fois hier soir les
flics ont demandé à jean marc de baisser
la sono les voisins se sont plaints de
tapage nocturne
de plus la meinau a été un des quartiers
qui a drainé le moins de spectateurs
seuls moments de vrai silence comme
partout d'ailleurs la chanson des
enfants et c'est vrai qu'ils sont
mignons sur scène ce n'est pas toujours
le cas le reste du temps leurs nounous
arnaud a bien de la patience et surtout
une bonne dose d'autorité mais tous
l'acceptent au début qu'on a su qu'on
allait avoir une ou là tous cru que
c'était une vieille femme avec une robe
des titres aux deux parties et on a été
très étonné de voir que c'était un jeune
homme très mignon avec un superbe
ensemble des sandalettes très à la mode
et très cool on était vraiment très
étonné et le soir quand il venait nous
donner des bisous ça gratte et parce
qu'ils étaient mal
il était mal rasé et son surnom c'est
super nounou dernier quartier de la
tournée hautepierre un ensemble de
quinze mille habitants dont les premiers
immeubles sont sortis de terre en 1975
structure originale divisé en 7 miles ce
quartier est le seul à afficher sa
douceur de vivre ici pas de gigantisme
les aires de jeu sont présentes partout
lieu stratégique de rencontre des jeunes
les moins de 20 ans représentent 50 % de
la population
un fait sociologique qui ne se traduit
pas vraiment dans les faits le centre
culturel du maillon ne concerne pas la
population du quartier
certes il y a le terrain aventure la
maison de l'enfance et activités les
paroisses et le centre sportif mais ces
structures ne peuvent pas répondre à
toutes les demandes et notamment à celle
des adolescents
on parle bien d'un projet de centre
socioculturel mais on n'a pas vraiment
dépassé les promesses électorales et les
habitants demandent à être consultés
pour éviter les erreurs
commises avec le maillon la ville de
crainte de perdre la maîtrise du projet
n'est pas chaude comme elle n'était pas
chaude d'ailleurs pour installer cette
statue devant la maison de l'enfance
d'aucuns à la mairie estimé que le
quartier ne le méritait pas heureusement
que l'artiste henin qui a fait don de
son oeuvre a insisté pour qu'elle soit
érigé ici à la surprise du quartier
personne ne les avait prévenu de son
arrivée
d'abord il y a eu le socle en béton et
au moins de juin la statue fille ou
garçon joueur de flûte ou de pipeau les
gens n'en savent rien mais les enfants
l'ont adopté et elle n'a subi aucune
dégradation
c'est moche de faire a priori les procès
d'intention on verra bien à la longue si
la structure du quartier ne favorise pas
beaucoup la communication l'émail vivent
un peu en vase clos
il est une population qui oublie les
frontières naturelles que sont les axes
de circulation et les dangers qu'il
représente
ce sont les jeunes seulement si les
contacts existent il n'est pas toujours
facile de monter un projet en commun
c'est plutôt un quartier fait pour les
enfants
on se sent bien on grandit très bien il
ya une multitude de plusieurs races ses
158 multiraciale jeunesse à l'âge de 11
ans et puis bon gsm intégré assez
facilement
j'ai même se créer un petit complexe
personnel d'activité c'est un groupe de
danse on essaie de faire un projet
c'est-à-dire de monter un petit
spectacle qui pouvait rassembler tous
les jeunes de pierre mais ça n'a pas
abouti parce que bon il n'était pas
motivé bon ils ont d'autres intérêts que
les miens c'est bien dommage parce que
je peux dire que c'est un beau quartier
et on préfère bonnes choses ce soir le
spectacle aura lieu comme d'habitude à
21h sur la scène extérieure du maillon à
hautepierre le brin de bonheur et invite
tous les habitants à lundi pour le
dernier journal de la tournée celui de
l'apothéose à la cathédrale au revoir
amis du petit écran